Instructor: Let's
take some time to learn all
about generators in ES6.
Currently with functions in
JavaScript, when you run a
function, it runs top to bottom
and that function is done.
However, with a generator
function, what we are
essentially going to be making
is a function that you can start
and stop, or a function that you
can pause for an indefinite
amount of time, and a function
that you can pass additional
information to at a later point
in time. When we create a
generator function, what you do
is you put an asterisk after the
keyword function. We'll look at
the syntax for doing it with a
method in a bit. Then, we
learn a new keyword, that is
called yield. The yield keyword
is sort of like a return for now.
If I were to return from a
function, that would be it for
the function. But if we yield
from a function,
what that will do is it
will return that one item until
the function is then called
again. I could yield Wes, and
then I could yield Kate, and
then I could yield Snickers.
That function will need to be
called three times in order for
me to get all of that
information. This is a generator
function. The only thing that is
different is that we have an
asterisk here, and we yield
values from it. To use a
generator function, what you
need to do is first invoke this
function and store that in a
variable. I'm going to say,
const people = listPeople. Let's
take a look at it in the browser
here. We have people. Did
that give me Wes, Kate, and
Snickers? No. That gives me this,
which is a generator. It is
currently suspended, which means
it's not running, and there's
really no other information
about it on there. Now, how
do we get this information out
of there? We call .next on the
generator. We say, people .next.
That returns to us -- this is
kind of interesting -- it
returns to us not Wes, but it
returns to us an object. In
that object we have the value,
which you would expect, and then
we have another property called
done. That means is this
generator done running? Well,
it's not, because we've only run
it once, and Wes is being
returned. You could probably
imagine, I call people .next and
that gives me value Kate, done
false. Then we call it once more,
and we get value Snickers, still
done false. Call it once more,
and you get done is true, and
obviously, we don't get a value
there. You see how we can
create these functions that
offer up maybe multiple returns
to us? Then when we want to use
it, we simply just call .next on
that generator. It will give us
sort of the next thing in the
line. I've hard-coded these
values here, but those yields
could be generated dynamically
with you. If you had some
variables inside of here, maybe
it would say, let i = 0The first
time we'll yield i. Then we'll
do i++. Then the next time we'll
yield i again. Let's say, i++,
and you could obviously do this
in a loop as well. The third
time we'll yield i. Now every
single time that I call it, I'm
going to say, people .next, what
that does is it creates a
variable called i, it set to
zero when I initialized it here
and the first time we yield the
variable i. The reference to
the variable i is scoped to this
function right here, and that is
kept. When I were to call people .
next again, the variable i is
still living inside of this
function, because it is not yet
done. I call it again and again
and again. Finally, we hit done
true, and it gets cleaned up
inside of that. The things to
know, this is a generator
function, it will keep its
variables until it's finished,
and you can yield multiple
values from it. Let's look at
another example where we iterate
through an array. Instead of
just console.logging them or
showing them all at once, we're
going to use next, next, next to
get through them. I've got an
array of inventors here. I'm
going to create a new generator
function called, loop. I'm
going to say, function* loop,
and that loop is going to take
in an array. Inside of it, we
need to do our looping. We would
use, for const item of, we're
going to use for of here, array.
Or you can think of that as a
const inventor of inventors.
Then for each one, we are going
to yield the item. That's
kind of interesting here,
because we aren't giving
ourselves three yields, we're
simply just giving ourselves one
yield. That's going to create
one, two, three, four, five, six,
seven yields for us when we loop.
The generator is smart enough to
know that when there are no more
to loop through, the entire
function will be done. How do
we actually call it? We have to
create that generator. I'm going
to say, const inventor gen =
loop through the inventors.
That's the array that we have
right here. You'll see that
we don't have it anywhere in
here. You don't actually see the
inventors getting console.logged.
Even if I console.log the
inventors right here, do you
expect to see the inventors log
as soon as we create the
generator? No. It actually
doesn't show up until we do the
first next. We'll say,
inventor gen, that's our
generator there. If we want to
call it, we call .next against
it. The first time we see that
huge array of all the inventors,
but then we see this. The object,
where is it done, no, and then
the value is Albert Einstein.
That's the first one there. I
could call inventor gen .next.
That will give me the next one
value, one little trick you can
do is you can just tack on .
value onto the end if you don't
care about the done status,
Galileo,
Curie, Kepler, Copernicus -- I
don't know how to say that --
and then we're done. You see
how we went through it. I could
keep calling this until we're
done, but what's really cool
about that is it will just
finish once it actually went
through every single one. Again,
we did a yield inside of here
and a yield returned multiple
values to us.